Welcome back everyone this is going to
be my new thor 4 love and thunder video
we just got a new first look preview
from the set so we'll break it down
i'll also explain how this is connected to what's
going on with the loki series because we're going
to get episodes of that pretty soon too this
spring be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i'll be doing episodes for all the disney
plus series this year obviously all the movies too
thankfully finally getting some movies this year
after 2020 with no marvel movies but in the new
previews that have been posting you can see that
valkyrie has had the asgardians build another
massive theater stage overlooking the coastline of
new asgard since the events of avengers end game
and even though a lot of people saw this stage
going up and correctly guess what it was being
used for in the movie just a couple days ago we
also got a separate first look at matt damon luke
hemsworth and melissa mccarthy believe it or not
as fake hella on the stage filming their scenes
as you probably guessed they're all there doing
another fake play and this time the play that
they're doing is based on the events of thor
ragnarok they're just making fun of that movie
the same way that loki's play from ragnarok
was parodying the plot of thor the dark world
it seems like the scene from ragnarok that they're
replaying is basically the whole first act of the
movie because matt damon's fake loki gets a couple
costume changes like you see him in loki's black
suit from when he and thor go to find odin on
earth sam neil is also back playing fake odin
again and he's dressed in that same leisure suit
from ragnarok and luke hemsworth chris hemsworth's
real life brother is also back wearing thor's same
casual outfit as funny as these fake plays are i
feel like it's also an extra level of funny that
you have someone as famous as matt damon melissa
mccarthy and chris hemsworth's real brother
playing fake thor then later you see them filming
all the hella stuff just replaying the events
of odin's death on the cliffs where they would
eventually build new asgard and then where hella
shows up because when odin dies his enchantment
binding hela in her prison falls allowing her
to escape if it wasn't clear that's why hella
shows up in ragnarok right as odin dies because
he had an enchantment binding her in her prison
but it's not clear how long this play goes on
before they stop like during ragnarok when they
were doing the fake play they only did part of
the story of the movie through loki's death so i'm
guessing they only get through part of the plot of
ragnarok here before somebody shows up like thor
shows up and stops them and they go on to the rest
of the plot of the film and if it wasn't clear
too also a really cool easter egg for new asgard
when odin is dying in ragnarok here and he tells
thor this would be a fine place for asgard talking
about building new asgard here on this cliff face
this is that same town tonsburg norway that was
featured in the flashbacks at the very beginning
of the first thor movie like in the ancient
flashbacks in his war with the frost giants
then this same town tonsberg shows up again at the
beginning of the captain america movie and we find
out it's where odin hid the tesseract so this town
this place where they built new asgard townsburg
was kind of like odin's favorite place on earth to
go you also notice in these new scenes thor's two
goats are here meaning that he's arrived from
some adventure that he's been on i'm assuming
that the play also takes place relatively early
in the film and because it was a loki pretending
to be fake odin that ordered them to do the play
during ragnarok you also have to assume that it's
valkyrie who's now king of asgard ordering them
to do this play based on the events of ragnarok
so it'll be funny to see how she changed the story
of ragnarok for the play just to make fun of thor
like you have to imagine thor showing up on
his two ghosts like hey i'm back everybody
and then finding them making fun of him in another
separate play like oh not this again my earlier
guess when they announced that matt damon was
coming back for thor 4 was that they'd bring
him back as fake loki and it would play into the
christian bale core of the god butcher storyline
and gorr would just eventually show up and kill
fake loki because that's this whole thing killing
all the gods around the universe indiscriminately
and gorr never knew the real loki or the real thor
before the events of the movie so he just as
easily mistake the fake versions doing the play
as the real versions of thor and loki trying to
slaughter them in the play itself is also relevant
to the new version of thor's hammer like we see
the old one getting smashed in this version of
the play we know they're doing the jane foster
thor so everyone has questions about how they'd
explain her wielding a version of thor's hammer
because the last time we saw it the original
one was still in pieces after ragnarok but here
in this brand new behind the scenes video that
one of the stuntmen posted then quickly deleted
hopefully he didn't get fired for posting this
you actually see chris hemsworth in the middle of
a huge stunt scene wielding mjolnir so i feel like
the easiest assumption to make would be that they
just reforge the pieces of the original hammer or
they get another hammer from another universe and
also because i always see questions about this in
the comments on thor videos the extra version
of thor's hammer that they had during avengers
end game that they stole from the events of thor
the dark world captain america took that hammer
back to the events of dark world when he took the
infinity stones back so in the main mcu timeline
in present day there's no version of mjolnir
unless you reforge one or go get another new
one from another universe i don't know how
twisty they're planning on getting with this
whole multiverse plot like we're just seeing that
culminate on Wandavision right now because thor 4
is already super twisty with the jane foster
thor stuff and then all the guardians of the
galaxy crossover stuff and the alternate universe
version of loki from avengers end game showing up
you have to remember that that version of loki
created a new timeline when he stole the tesseract
so he's fully an alternate version of loki at this
point completely different from the loki that died
during avengers infinity war so there are a couple
questions that we probably won't find out about
until they drop that first trailer it's probably
going to be a while before we see that we've
already seen thor's new look during the movie and
the guardians of the galaxy like thor's looking
like a thunderstrike costume basically combined
with a classic thor comic book costume from the
jack kirby comics even the costume designer for
the movie was posting on his instagram hyping
this up like i can't wait for everybody to see
this it's going to be crazy so basically what's
going on here is just a combination of the eric
masterson thunderstrike costume with the red vest
it's a little too hard to read the logo on his
t-shirt but i'm sure the logo is also a reference
to something from the comics too the whole thing
with thunderstrike in the comics is that was the
name that was given to the eric masterson version
of thor when he became his own separate version
of the character like he started out as just a
regular person then fully became an alternate
version of thor he even got his own spin-off comic
that lasted for a couple years originally i think
he was a construction worker or an architect he
wound up saving thor's life then odin later merged
the real version of thor's consciousness with
him and eventually gave him his own hammer
he wound up joining the thoracore he crossed over
with beta ray bill i know we're all hoping to see
a version of beta ray bill show up during thor 4
just another big twist upon many other big twists
but he still got stormbreaker during the movie i
feel like that's not a huge surprise just because
the last time we saw him at the end of avengers
end game he was going off with the guardians of
the galaxy for just more space adventures just to
find himself like okay i'm going to go try and be
true to myself but this is why he looks very much
like a construction worker version of thor it's
just a big 80s thunderstrike easter egg the whole
logo for the movie thor love and thunder also
looks very 80s inspired make all the thor heavy
metal jokes you want i also love the upgraded
guardians of the galaxy costumes too like you look
at star-lord's costume he's also got a bit more of
a beard too like they're really embellishing here
you notice his gold shoulder pads this much more
intricate designs it almost looks like a costume
that's inspired by ego the living planet's costume
the way james gunn talked about it he did give
some notes and help them with the guardians parts
of thor 4 but there's not a ton of guardian stuff
in the movie just because it is mostly a thor film
and they're going to be shooting guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 later this year after the
suicide squad movie comes out the way he talks
about it they haven't changed the plot a ton
like he finished writing guardians 3 a couple
years ago before all the big drama went down
so the only real big changes they probably made
to the script are just because of the way they
changed the order in which the movies are coming
out because originally guardians 3 was supposed
to come out last summer like we would have seen it
during 2020 already and for everyone that's asking
about adam warlock for the most part i don't think
we're going to see him show up until guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 the new version of loki from
avengers end game that we're going to be seeing
will be coming from the events of his loki series
like we just found out we're going to be getting
those episodes in june during the events of that
he'll be working for the time variance authority
going around to alternate timelines trying to take
down alternate versions of himself other versions
of loki that are going completely off the rails
like as you can see all these different events
that he goes to it seems like different versions
of the earth all wind up just going to complete
like things go terribly in all these alternate
realities so the time variance authority are
basically like the time police or the time cops
of the marvel cinematic universe so because he has
the ability to jump around alternate timelines
using the time variance authority technology
it's pretty easy to assume how he winds up coming
back and crossing over with the events of thor 4.
and if you guys didn't see they've already
confirmed that loki is going to get a season 2
meaning that loki will probably survive
the events of thor 4 like after the events
of thor 4 he'll just go on to the events of loki
season 2 whatever the story of that's going to be
but at some point he will show up so everyone
just post all your theories in the comments below
and obviously really big news this week my
Wandavision finale video is going to post
friday just like normal but i'll do another bonus
video tomorrow for that the way the director and
the show runner are talking about it they're not
going to answer every single question that they
brought up a lot of that stuff is going to be left
for doctor strange too but we will have enough
clues to solve a couple of the big mysteries
while you wait for everything click here for
my Wandavision episode 9 trailer video and click
here for all my Wandavision finale predictions
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!